hallo ihr lieben endlich zeige ich euch
meine marzipantorte auf instagram habt
ihr schon fotos davon gesehen ich habe
sie schon ein paar mal hinter den
kulissen gebacken und wir sind uns alle
einig eine leckere marzipantorte
beinhaltet neben marzipan wandel der
biscuit eine lag susanne kleben
irgendwas wichtiges und irgendwas
kitschiges und in dieser torte ist alles
vereint und ich sage euch ist es die
leckerste marzipantorte die ich und samt
meine ganze familie meine freundin je
gegessen haben und wir starten hier
zuallererst mit dem wandel biscuit boden
dafür benötigen wir ja die habe ich in
eiweiß und eigelb getrennt außerdem
zucker mehl speisestärke backpulver
vanille zucker und etwas salz für den
perfekten vanille diskutiert werden die
eier separat aufgeschlagen und genau das
machen wir jetzt auch als erstes das
heißt ich lebe jetzt meinen eiweiß in
die rührschüssel wir können natürlich
auch im handwerk gerät verwenden ist gar
kein problem gebe da eine prise salz mit
hinzu das bewegt einfach dass die
altersstruktur viel schneller zerstört
wird und jetzt frage ich das auch falls
fahrstufe circa zwei minuten lang
richtig schön schaumig
nach zwei minuten gehen wir die hälfte
unseres zuckers hinzu dass jetzt einfach
dass das am besten noch ein bisschen
stabiler wird und die andere hälfte
benötigen wir gleich noch und dann
nochmal weitere zwei minuten lang
richtig schön steif schlagen so die
eiweiß masse also die sogenannte baiser
masse ist jetzt fertig schaut mal sieht
das nicht länger aus könnte mich schon
direkt reinlegen
aber wir machen nichts weiter mit dem
eigelb und dafür werde ich jetzt ganz
gut eine neue schüssel holen und dann
zeige ich euch jetzt weitergeht in einer
neue schüsse wird jetzt ein gelb mit dem
restlichen zucker und dem vanillezucker
verrät und zwar ungefähr drei bis vier
minuten bis es richtig schön hell cremig
ist
[Musik]
die eigelb masse ist jetzt richtig schön
cremig und auch ein bisschen heller
geworden und als nächstes vereinen wie
die eier wieder miteinander indem wir
das eiweiß zur eigelb meisterin und dann
nimmt er am besten ein teig könnt ihr
das richtig vorsichtig in zwei bis drei
schritten machen
[Musik]
so die besemer es ist schön
eingearbeitet und um die flüssigkeit
jetzt ins nächste level zu bringen
nehmen wir uns jetzt ein sieb und 7 die
trockenen zutaten durch und das mache
ich auch in zwei schritten
[Musik]
den vorbereiteten teig füllen wir jetzt
in unsere springform hier habe ich einen
durchmesser von 26 cm
es geht aber auch zum beispiel 24 cm
so den teig habe ich jetzt noch ein
bisschen glatt gestrichen und jetzt
wandert er in den vorgeheizten backofen
bei 180 grad ober und unterhitze für 20
minuten und anschließend das wie ein
vollständig auskühlen
während der vanille wie es gilt jetzt
auskühlt kümmern wir uns um die leckere
cremen und diese creme ist die perfekte
komponente zudem bizkit boden und zum
marzipan aber wir lassen die zutaten ist
erstmal selber für sich sprechen wir
benötigen schlagsahne seine fest sahne
quark außerdem mascarpone erneut seine
fest schoko treppchen mandarin orangen
aus der dose aprikosen fruchtaufstrich
und puderzucker so ihr lieben wir
kümmern uns jetzt zuallererst nicht
schlagsahne die gebe ich jetzt in meine
rührschüssel und schlage sie einmal
steif und deswegen habe ich auch dass
seine fest aufgeteilt ein teil kommt
jetzt mit susanne und der andere teil
mit zu mascarpone creme
[Musik]
so nach drei minuten ist die sahne
richtig schön fest wichtig ist nur dass
die sahne wirklich ganz kalt aus dem
kühlschrank kommt dann lässt sie sich
auch ohne probleme aufschlagen und ich
werde jetzt ungefähr die hälfte weg
nehmen für die deko
die kommt dann in den kühlschrank und
mit der restlichen sahne machen wird
dann die creme weiter und jetzt kümmern
wir uns um die restlichen zutaten das
heißt sahnequark mascarpone und
puderzucker gebe ich jetzt in eine
separate schüsse und rührt das mit dem
schneebesen um das heißt hier aber auch
die keine maschine mehr
[Musik]
sobald sich die zutaten guten
miteinander verbunden haben den wir hier
noch seine fest rein
das hilft einfach dass die masse ein
bisschen schneller stabilisiert und ein
bisschen stabiler bleibt und dann wird
die klimatisierte
und jetzt kommt der knüller erleben das
ist so zum ende des jahres nochmal so
meine highlight entdeckung dieser
fruchtaufstrich ist so lecker sonst muss
ich den immer erst in die mikrowelle
geben und dann nochmal passieren durch
ein feines sieb fällt hier weg gibt
jetzt zwei bis drei esslöffel ich sag
lieber drei esslöffel in die creme und
schmeckt es noch mal richtig schön
fruchtig nach aprikose richtig lecker
[Musik]
so das ganze hat sich auch gut verbunden
und zu guter letzt wird jetzt nur noch
die steif geschlagene sahne untergehoben
dafür nehme ich jetzt lieber den teig
schon nicht mehr den schneebesen so
so die zarte creme ist schon total
lecker aber noch lange nicht fertig
definiert noch ein bisschen auf dafür
gebe ich die hälfte der krimi ziert
zurück in die schüssel und dann die
toppings rhein zu geben jetzt geben wir
in die eine hälfte der creme unsere
mandarinen orangen und das wasser davon
dürfte ihn nicht wegschicken das
brauchen wir später doch das habe ich
nämlich auch hinter mir aufbewahrt und
dann bringen wir das einmal gut um
[Musik]
und in die zweite hälfte kommen jetzt
die schoko tröpfchen und ich bin da
total schmerzfrei bei mir kommt gleich
die ganze packung rein
[Musik]
und jetzt kommen wir zum schichten
unserer marzipantorte dafür habe ich
mein wissen boden einmal in der hälfte
durch geteilt den tortenboden auf eine
tortenplatte gelegt und gibt da jetzt
ein bug ram drumherum alternativ geht
auch der sand eurer springform und ich
habe euch ja anfangs gesagt dass ich den
saft aus der mandarin lose aufbewahrt
habt und damit trinken wir jetzt den
boden und das macht den boden jetzt noch
mal ein bisschen saftiger und gibt noch
einen leckeren geschmack als nächstes
gehen wir schon mal die hälfte der creme
drauf das heißt die hälfte mit den
mandarinen stückchen und dann verteile
ich das noch mal glatt und gibt den
zweiten boden obendrauf
[Musik]
so als nächstes kommt dies creme mit den
schokostückchen auf die torte und ich
mache das gerne so dass die wirklich
oben drauf kommt damit wir später das
alles schön glatt streichen können denn
dann kommt ja noch unsere marzipan
schicht da drauf
[Musik]
sobald ihr das seien glatt verstrichen
habt müsst ihr stark sein und das ganze
kommt jetzt zum kühlen in den
kühlschrank ich würde sagen mindestens
zweieinhalb stunden dann fängt das ganze
an schon fest zu werden
aber in meinem fall kommt das ganze ist
über nacht in den kühlschrank natürlich
abgelegt haben wir auch nichts drankommt
und dann sehen wir uns morgen wieder so
ihr lieben meine torte durfte jetzt die
ganze nacht kühlen und jetzt kümmern wir
uns um die deko und dafür zeige ich euch
die zutaten
wir benötigen marzipanrohmasse etwas
puderzucker aprikosen fruchtaufstrich
haselnuss krokant und die sahne die wir
uns zur seite gelegt haben wir kümmern
uns jetzt zuallererst in die
marzipanrohmasse und die lässt sich am
besten kneten in dem etwas puderzucker
nimmt ich gebe dem puderzucker jetzt
direkt auf die arbeitsfläche und wird es
dann so ein bisschen durchkneten
[Musik]
und sobald ihr merkt dass europa nicht
mehr ganz so klebrig ist also ein
bisschen klebrig ist der immer aber
sobald es so ein bisschen geschmeidiger
gewonnen ist zeige ich euch trick 17
dann nehmt ihr euch nämlich ein
backpapier legen hier auf die
arbeitsfläche marzipan einmal darüber
lägen noch mal ein bisschen puderzucker
und dann einfach ausrollen am besten mit
so einem silikon aus roller wenn ihr
kein habt könnt ihr auch eine zweite
backpapier schicht darüber legen dann
geht's auch super einfach sobald ihr
dann eure marzipan einigermaßen rund
ausgerollt haben nimmt ihr euch einen
tortenring ein teller irgendwas was ihr
da habt was den gleichen durchmesser wie
die oberfläche der torte hat dann
kontrolliert einmal ob es auch wirklich
groß genug ausgerollt wurde ja das passt
und jetzt drückt ihr einfach an und dann
sticht ihr euch quasi einen runden kreis
aus für die oberfläche der torte
[Musik]
den tortenring lösen wir jetzt und dann
kommt die marzipan decke obendrauf
[Musik]
die marzipan decke ist jetzt drauf und
als nächstes nehmen wir uns die sahne
die wir von gestern noch übrig haben und
sprechen damit ganz dünn den rand ein
aber nicht die ganze sache auf brauchen
wir brauchen einen teil noch später für
die deko
[Musik]
das grundgerüst steht schon mal und
jetzt kommt unser haselnuss krokant ins
spiel das geben wir jetzt noch mal schön
an den rand der torten das haftet super
an der saane
[Musik]
und es gibt er diesen zitronen trick
kennt ihr mit sicherheit und zu nehmt
ihr euch da eine aufgeschnittene zitrone
gibt haselnuss kokam drauf oder das was
sie eben an die torte haben möchtet so
und dann einfach die zitronenscheibe an
die sahne drücken dann haftet das wie
von alleine macht euch die finger nicht
dreckig aber ich weiß nicht wieso man
davon ist finde ich auch weiß nicht was
ich davon halten soll
was man ihr dann benutze diesen trick
gerne schreibt zumal in die kommentare
wirklich mal sehr interessieren ich
mache jetzt mit den händen weiter und
jetzt kann man wirklich seiner fantasie
freien lauf lassen was die deko angeht
ich mag es jetzt bei der torte lieber
schlicht und elegant und nehme jetzt
meint orten einteiler und teil die torte
in 16 stücke ein
die restliche sahne habe ich mir meinen
spritzbeutel gefüllt und haben vorne
eine offene stelle mit 16 millimeter
durchmesser
haltet euch aber auch eine kleinere
sterne parat die hier die brauchen wir
später auch die hatten durchmesser von
10 mm und jetzt einfach bei den
markierungen santo verspritzen
[Musik]
und jetzt nehmt ihr euch einfach die
kleinere tülle legt sie auf die große
dann spart ihr euch einen spritzbeutel
und spritzt kleine tupfer vor die großen
[Musik]
so und für das optische highlight und
natürlich auch das geschmackliche
highlight geben wir jetzt noch den
fruchtaufstrich einmal auf die großen
tupfer und zwar nur mit ich so ein ganz
kleines bisschen
[Musik]
fertig unsere marzipantorte ist fertig
ihr braucht sie gar nicht weiter kühlen
die können sie sofort an schneiden oder
aber organisation ja mach ich auch cool
richtig richtig cool wenn ihr aus
organisatorischen gründen die torte
einen tag vorher machen müsst macht das
ist gar kein problem sie hält sich drei
tage lang mindestens frisch durch die
sahne also allerhöchstens viel länger
würde ich länger hält sie auch gar nicht
ganz ehrlich so jetzt seid ihr schon mal
hinweis die genauen mengenangaben stehen
unten in der infobox hinterlasst mir
gerne euer feedback unten in den
kommentaren ich freue mich mal sehr von
euch zu lesen
hinterlässt diesem video natürlich ein
bäumchen nach oben und ein kostenloses
abo damit ihr auch nichts mehr verpasst
und dann sehen wir uns beim nächsten mal
wieder auf die gis kitchen tschüss
[Musik]